[Music]
thanks a lot everyone for joining us
today so I'm gonna be joined by Venky
Iyer here my name is Ryan Lippert and
what we'll be talking about today is
just the advantage of managed and when
we talk about that we're really talking
about Hadoop and migrating that from AWS
to GCP now before I turn things over to
Venky for the real he's the real star of
the show here what I'm going to do is
just quickly walk through data proc in
general and what we see is our
advantages but really that's gonna be
hit home a lot better I think by Venky
whenever he gets up and tells his own
customer story about things so let's
talk about data proc and just you know
what is it and then you know why do we
think that's important from a Google
perspective so I think that the best
place to start there if you're going to
talk about data proc is to talk about
traditional spark and Hadoop clusters
and the way that we think about those in
the way that those actually go into
implementation and operation so with a
traditional cluster you know what you
end up having is within your cluster you
have your data technology your
governance you have security in there
and then that lies on top of operations
and management now the issue with those
traditional SPARC and Hadoop clusters is
that they're not really integrated with
other tools they've got to be shared
between many and it's really difficult
to make those changes and those changes
end up creating something that we like
to call the D value chain of big data to
some extent and so this is probably
familiar to anyone who's provisioned
Hadoop clusters on-premises one way or
the other but you've got to obtain
servers first from there you have to
configure servers after that you're
installing the open source software then
you're configuring that software from
there you're optimizing it then you need
to debug it and then you can finally get
to the point where you're ready to start
to process data and so that's a long
cycle and any time that you want to
start that cycle over again to scale
you've got to go through each one of
those individual steps likewise if you
get to the end of things and you say hey
actually what we need to do is a
reconfiguration here you're looking at
restarting that halfway through the
process and so what you end up with is a
lot of lost time and then that lost time
is also sunk costs that end up going
into getting to a point where really
what you want to end up doing is
processing data at the end of the day
and so if we can get closer to that
processing data piece of things
going to be really what our customers
are actually looking for so the the
cycle that we just showed on that last
slide it uses it usually leads to pain
so the first kind of pain is scaling
pain so anytime that you need to add new
capacity in you end up with a lag
between when your needs come on and then
when you can actually get that into and
get that out and into production and
that's because there's just so much time
that's required to be able to actually
get the truck roll out and make that
happen there's also an issue from a
utilization Pat Payne perspective so the
way that you usually see it is you've
got your cluster it's up and running
it's taking in data at the time that it
needs to its processing data as it needs
to but then there are big inactive times
as well and so you're still paying for
that in active time particularly if it's
not a managed type solution and then
what that leads to is cost pain and it
cost pain what you'd see is you're still
reducing your costs as you move to
Hadoop over legacy technologies but what
you're doing is because you've over
provisioned and because you've got
inactive clusters your cost is always
going to be more than what it actually
should be if you could actually get to a
point where you're only using what you
need and so that's why we think that
really the cluster and the platform
should work together and that's what
we've tried to build here and so when we
think about that the stuff that you'd
rather not care about every time that's
the governance the security the
operations and management those are all
very important things when it comes to
running a cluster but it's not really
what you care about and that's the data
technology that you're running in it you
really want to get to the point where
you're looking at your analytics you're
looking at the solutions and you're
looking at the data processing and being
able to focus on that as opposed to
everything else within your stack and so
that's why we've developed cloud data
proc and that's where we think that our
solutions pretty differentiated from
what you'd see out there in the market
more broadly so Cloud Data proc it's
just it's fast it's easy to use it's
low-cost it's fully managed and it's all
on Google cloud platform which means
that it's integrated with the other
tools that we have within our platform
as well and so that really allows you to
get up and moving a lot faster than you
would be able to if you were trying to
run this on your own whether in a cloud
and just doing yourself hosted or
on-premises and so our vision as I
mentioned fast so let's make sure that
it takes seconds to spin things up not
minutes not weeks
definitely not months as it can
sometimes be we want things to be easy
as well so be an expert with your data
but not necess
surely the infrastructure let's focus on
what we're doing from a data perspective
and then let's make it so that you only
pay for what you're using as opposed to
everything else in your everything that
you've got static that could be in your
stack that's not actually working on
things and so when we actually look
particularly that last point from a cost
perspective we've had some some analysts
come out with some studies that say that
when you look at cloud data proc
particularly relative to on-premises
it's 54 7% less expensive than that and
then even when you look at EMR it's
going to be 32% less expensive so the
way that that ends up happening is as we
move from on-premises to just doing it
on compute engine or potentially in
another cloud then all the way across
the cloud data proc what you see is that
on-premises your self managed for
everything from code down to the
creation and deployment and then as you
start to move from left to right on the
screen from a compute engine perspective
that and Google starts to take over
things like connectivity deployment and
creation but when you get towards Cloud
Data proc you can see that the only
thing that the customers and users end
up being responsible for is really
getting to a point where they're they're
putting in their custom code and then
everything else along the way is taken
care of for you and so when we generally
look at folks who are starting to do
these migrations one way or the other if
it's a lift and shift from another cloud
if it's even a lift and shift within
Google from self-hosted to running data
proc or particularly if it's on Prem to
end of the cloud there's a set of common
six common kind of principles that we
would typically look at and say hey
here's what you should be thinking about
the first is separating compute and
storage as you move into data proc the
ability to do that is going to allow you
to move a lot more efficiently use
ephemeral and long-lived clusters so
kind of start to try to classify them in
one way or the other if you have a
cluster that always needs to stay on
make sure that you've got your the data
that needs to be processed in that
cluster and then the ones that you can
spin up and spin down quickly you know
separate those out you also want to
right-size the clusters per use case as
well so understand what your use case is
and spin up clusters that make sense for
that this create and delete clusters
often goes very well with the ephemeral
and long-lived clusters there's no need
to keep those up and running if you can
spin them spin them down and then with a
90 second sick
the 92nd spin up time for those clusters
you can bring them back any time that
you need to replacing HDFS with cloud
storage and then finally using data prog
jobs through the api's that we offer so
that's a good Google overview but I
think what everyone's really here for is
to hear more from a customer to hear
about how this actually goes you know
potentially warts and all whenever it
looks like a lift and shift here so with
that I'd like to introduce Venky Venky
is a software engineer from thumbtack so
everyone give a good hand - Venky here
thanks Ryan hello everyone I'm Venky I'm
a software engineer at thumbtack in the
fall of 2016 we decided to move our
self-hosted a Hadoop set up near our
infrastructure set up from AWS to manage
services on Google Google cloud and
today I'm here to tell you that story
but before I begin let me offer you a
quick intro on what is thumbtack in the
world around us it would seem that
capitalism exists to make people lazier
and we do our bit by solving trying to
solve this problem
why is it so hard to hire a plumber or a
gardener or a photographer you can buy
anything you want with one click you can
book travel around the world in a matter
of minutes but when you want to hire a
piano tutor for your kid you are forced
to use the analog world you know maybe
talk to somebody look up Yelp or yellow
pages and try and make a few calls and
see what works out thumbtack is an
online marketplace that connects
customers to professionals who match
their specific job requirements their
schedule and their budget and thumbtack
is also the platform that enables
professionals and small business owners
to focus on what they do best to focus
on their core trade and thumbtack works
on their behalf to acquire customers
with high intent for them and like any
other internet company internet business
in today's age we are highly reliant on
data we need data for core product
features like matching that I just
talked about
for paid customer acquisition through
SEM channels we need timely and reliable
data to infer our Tom top line metrics
like customer growth and revenue we need
data for analyzing our experiments we
need data to train our machine learning
models I'm sure a lot of you will find
this all too familiar so let's begin the
story of how we are thumbtack you know
attempted to solve for these
requirements and we begin sorry and and
we begin with a state we were in a
little more than three years ago the v-0
infrastructure or rather the lack of it
so we had this PHP website and we used
to run a daemon that would collect
events from those website servers which
we would dump it into MongoDB for
whatever reason we had a bunch of Python
scripts that would read those events do
some data aggregation and do an in-place
update again for whatever reason and
querying this infrastructure was very
slow we could analyze only one
experiment at a time and if by chance
you wanted to find insights into
relational data you kind of go into a
sub completely different world of a
lucre instance which was hooked on to a
live PG replica so very fragile very
slow not very feature-rich
and yet somehow comprised of complex and
convoluted code so this was clearly a
problem statement that we had to kind of
attempt to solve and that began with our
first generation of infrastructure so we
set up cloud era Hadoop on a bunch of
AWS ec2 instances we set up SPARC on it
we converted all our data processing
from like random Python scripts or
whatever to Scala essentially SPARC jobs
we wrote all the data output in park'
format we configured Cloudera Impala as
a sequel engine on top of that park'
data and we use them we used a
visualization tool called mode and
hooked it on to the cloud or Impala so
that our analysts can now create fancy
dashboards this infrastructure was the
first
you know generation that powered our
experiment visualization tool that we
call prospect it also powered our first
ml prediction API serving which was
which we called matchbox and we set up
air flow we used air flow to orchestrate
all these jobs to define the schedules
to define the define the dependencies
between jobs on which should run after
what overall a huge step up from where
we were before but not without its
problems the first of which was we were
continually continuously playing musical
chairs with the capacity right this is
where the kind of the D value chain that
Ryan talked about kind of commences for
us jobs would step on each other
invariably what would happen is a lot of
scheduled mode reports would be
rescheduled to run at 7:00 a.m. or 8:00
a.m. so that people get fresh data when
they come to the office and they would
overload the cluster very frequently we
would field queries like hey my
dashboard looks off is is it a data
problem or did we really tank our
revenue yesterday so we clearly needed
to do something about the reliability of
data there and ironically in spite of
all that during mid-day if nobody is
running any ad hoc queries the entire
cluster was idols so there was very
little elasticity in our infrastructure
that we had set up data was replicated
within the HDFS it maintains multiple
copies but that was it
so we had this slight durability risk as
well and what it meant as a team for us
is this was a huge time sink in terms of
operational workload for engineers from
Google and Facebook and the like to
appreciate this a bit more I would like
to tell that this was a team of six
engineers responsible for everything
from setting up the clusters to setting
up Hadoop and spark on top of it to
actually writing the data infrastructure
that we would really need it so this was
a huge time saying so we had to kind of
view it at a point where we had to start
thinking forward on what how do we solve
these problems and these were our
alternatives the most obvious
was to kind of double down on the same
path which would have inevitably
translated into separating out our
compute and analysis clusters which
would have meant investing in some
cluster management tools that would help
us with capacity planning some maybe it
automates some operational tasks but to
summarize what would this would have
meant is we would have had to hire our
way out of that thing and for companies
like ours that thing is a lot easier
said than done so that was that was when
we started thinking about managed
solutions and these are the two options
that compare we got to compare
head-on-head
so data proc and bigquery offerings on
Google and EMR and redshift offering on
AWS so comparing data progeny amaur
amaur at the time took about 30 minutes
to spin up a cluster it has improved now
a little bit but again that really we
thought that really doesn't get us out
of this capacity planning thing right
you would still have to spin up clusters
and figure out how many jobs or which
jobs can be run on this one whereas
Google data proc can help us think in
terms of job scope clusters so I'll get
into a details of that a little bit and
comparing bigquery and redshift we we
definitely like bigquery more because 8
was truly serverless it supported nested
data types which we used a lot of and it
was an added advantage that it kind of
worked on Google sheets as a federated
data source which would please a lot of
people in the company so it was
definitely advantage Google at this
point and this is kind of the story that
led us to the decision point of where we
decided to take the plunge so in the
next section I want to talk about how do
we get on from there right decisions
like this are seldom unanimous there are
counter points within and outside the
team and even for us who are in favor
we had to acknowledge our fail ability
here we had to acknowledge you know is
this the right path or if it is how do I
prove it right so we started thinking
about how do we get some initial
success pointer sorry how do we say that
we are on the right track so for that
what we did is we partnered with our
analytics team to identify some of the
important data sets and just copied and
copied them over to bigquery and then
the mode visualization tool that I
talked about we pointed that to bigquery
instead so there was some work involved
in changing the sequel from the Impala
sequel dialect to bigquery standard
sequel dialect there are some minor
changes you had to handle the timestamp
fields differently and so on and so
forth so it took some kind of
documentation and some education part of
it but overall not such a daunting task
right and in order to keep that data of
fresh what we did was we leveraged our
air flow infrastructure and inserted a
small cross copy job at the end of our
data pipeline so you we had this bunch
of processing that would end up
producing a park' output and then we had
one downstream job that would take read
this part a file convert that into Avro
dump that into GCS and update that to
bigquery right so that data in bigquery
remains fresh while still all the
processing is on AWS so this gave us two
benefits in hindsight I think this
turned out to be a really good call a
because analysts were the number one
customers of this data infrastructure
gave a thumbs-up they found I mean their
queries they found a quick turnaround
time from bigquery the failure and
timeout rate was markedly lot lower than
before so it was an immediate win for
them so that was good
and this gave us a good migration path
right so now we could think about
migration without interrupting any of
the business workflows any of the
interrupting any of the other team's
plans your your dashboards will still
work the data is all still there while
in the background one data pipeline at a
time we can take and move it from AWS to
Google
so with that headwind we really double
down and started kind of building some
of the other pieces on top of Google
Cloud that really enabled us to leverage
this infrastructure effect
and now I'll kind of talk a little bit
more about job scope clusters right this
is an entire paradigm shift now instead
of thinking of setting up a cluster with
this many CPUs and this much memory and
figuring out how many jobs can enough
run on this cluster now we could think
about hey I have this job what resources
does this job need since the cluster can
be spun up in like 60 seconds or 90
seconds that job can go ahead and spin
up the cluster it needs and then just
run without any interference from any
other job it just kind of felt like good
parenting right job one you run in
cluster one job two you run in trust a -
no fighting and it worked and some of
the other things that we discovered
while we were setting up our info on
Google was we realized that for
downstream jobs it was much more
performant and cost-effective to read it
from GCS rather than bigquery so when
you dump data into bigquery you stage
that in GCS anyway because that's how
the BQ load works we just made sure that
we gave that path you know a formal you
know convention so that we can address
our data on GCS as well and downstream
spark jobs could just read data from GCS
we leveraged the audit logs from both
bigquery and data proc fed it back into
bigquery so that we can query it and
create dashboards on it and we use that
to create gain insights into our usage
and cost of how we are using this
platform and finally we use the
fine-grained data access and
management in bigquery to kind of really
share data sets to wide range of teams
including the contractors as well but
the migration was not without its
challenges right so the first two I
called out here are required non-trivial
amount of code refactoring now we are
dealing with clusters that we spin up
and down so HDFS is an ephemeral storage
now so we really had to move all our
data storage
into an object like we will cloud
storage at the time be query did not
support parquet so we had to convert
everything into Avro and we got into
some gnarly data conversion data type
conversion issues but yeah that needed
to be solved a couple of runtime
challenges one was a difference in
performance characteristics so data proc
tries to fit to spark executors per
worker and we realized that and it tries
to allocate like roughly 50% of
resources to each of those executors and
we realize that if you tune a memory a
little bit like heap memory or out of
heap memory data broke would some time
only showed you one executor on one
worker and we would be at a loss or we
are throwing like this we are spun up
this 24 node cluster but still it takes
twice as long I mean why and then we
realize it's only using half the cluster
so that took some kind of Sherlock work
and worth investigation type thing and
the other thing was cross cloud
networking now we are moving data back
and forth so we had to set up some
networking here we had to set up the
auth keys that can be kind of shared and
rotated in a good way and all these are
from a technical perspective and from a
management and organizational
perspective what it meant is the time
spent on migration is the time not spent
on the feature requests that all other
teams have so this is something that we
just asked the company to take us up on
good faith and we are grateful for them
for for their patience but we did
overcome it and we did end up having in
today's state we are leveraging Google
to a good effect
we have compounded the number of jobs
and queries we are running we create and
destroy more than 700 clusters per day
we run more than 12,000 queries a day we
added streaming ETL capabilities we used
deployment manager to man have this
entire configuration on GCPs code so all
in all I think we did kind of overcome
all that to come to a very good state
here and we also used the googles
organization
and projects kind of hierarchy to kind
of create multiple product projects and
to control data visibility and also to
kind of have a per department billing so
to speak so we could figure out where
our expenses are coming from yeah talk
about this right so that's kind of the
story of how we came to a decision point
why we decided GCP and how we migrated
to GCP and in this last section of this
stop I want to kind of just share the
thoughts as we reflect upon so what do
we kind of make off all that things how
does this project go for us right
starting with this question that did we
truly achieve what we set out to achieve
and several things come to come to mind
I mean we currently run a lot more like
I said a lot more queries lot more job
lot more capabilities on the data
infrastructure as well as we are now as
a team taking on more problems even
outside of the data scope so if you have
to condense all that into one word
that's time we gain time for a limited
set of engineers we really kind of
figured out that we could save time and
spend somewhere else wisely and one
other thing that I think about that we
could not have gained without this
migration is to truly democratize data
the scale of bigquery the scale and the
flexibility with the you know creating
both normal and materialized views and
have different ought scopes for a each
one of them has really helped us to
share data sets with almost all the
organizations all all the departments
within the company and everybody across
the company is leveraging that data so
that's a huge win for us so those are
the good aspects of it so there is also
kind of one more way to think about all
these things as you know there are
plenty of risks along the way so how do
you think we did with the risks starting
with planning fallacy so so this
this planning fallacy is when you know
when you're making a plan you were like
super optimistic I'll do this in like
three months
but you overshoot it right and we did
fell for this we we kind of thought that
we should be able to do this within six
months from MVP - all the way to the end
but we did bleed into the third quarter
of the migration but we did kind of put
our heads down and completed the other
kind of estimate that we overshot by a
lot is we thought we would spend less on
Google but that did not turn out to be
true but that's okay because now we are
actually spending more because we are
using that data a lot more we are
running a lot more jobs we are running a
lot more queries and that's where the
cost comes from the second kind of risk
I think about is the sunk cost fallacy
sometimes this migration kind of keep
going on for like months and months and
some somewhere along the half way
through you think about hey I've come
this far and that becomes the only
reason for just kind of keep going
forward it happens when you don't have
an option to go back or going back
becomes like really expensive right and
this is somewhere this is an item where
we think I think we did really well a
because we always had a path of going
back we didn't kind of dismantle our AWS
infrastructure until we were completely
here so if we had hit a roadblock if he
at any point of time thought that hey
this is not working out
we had other alternatives and one other
thing that helped us is we had scoped in
the beginning that we are only going to
move our data infrastructure and nothing
more right and that scope remain
unaltered throughout this project and
that was again one other good thing in
hindsight so these two are more with
respect to the migration migration
related risks the third risk I want to
talk about
it's more of an existential risk when
you operate in a multi cloud environment
so Conway's law I don't know if you have
heard about it it states that
organizations will produce designs that
will have the communication structures
that they have it in the organization
what it translates to in reality is if
you're one team is responsible for your
Google infrastructure if the other team
is response if some second team is
responsible for your AWS infrastructure
when you think about solutions can you
truly think about one single base you
know data center infrared
we can do that if the teams don't work
well together you would have one
solution here and one solution here that
would not talk to each other right so
this is like I said this is an
existential risk we're completely not
out of the woods yet
but the good thing is just being aware
of it is a very good step and this is
something that we have to be mindful of
from here on this never ends so that's
that was a like of brief scorecard on
how we did so now I would kind of take a
liberty to kind of give a scorecard on
how Google did overall I think the
uptime has been pretty solid the scale
that scale and load that we throw out
Google Google is like handled no big
deal their response their support teams
have been pretty responsive for both
like low priority issues as well as high
priority issues this were the good parts
but that does not mean that there were
no issues at all they're also a software
company they also rule out software
things go wrong some of the things I
wanted to highlight was like last year
we had a couple of bigquery related
incidents essentially they were breaking
changes they were not
backward-compatible changes at the
Google send that kind of cook got who
got our data processing to a grinding
halt one of this was for example the non
ability of Avro fields and malleability
of bigquery fields the requirements were
made strict that they should match which
wasn't the case before and we were
freely using strict fields and mapping
them to nullable fields in bigquery so
that broke everything the other thing
was again some charting changes that we
had to kind of
a particular variable and more recently
we had a bunch of issues with data proc
there was one where the GC images
weren't available there were a couple in
June again one related to some
networking and one was something else in
the back end and both of these were
unfortunately kind of impacted the
entire region so maybe that's one CVB or
that's a term that we use in thumbtack
called could be better so one could be
better that I would call out is probably
have a rollout plan that even if it goes
bad does not impact the entire region
maybe just a few easy switch in a region
but we did it did force us to kind of
think rethink and we were able to
leverage our airflow infrastructure to
move from a single region to be multi
region and since the big query and the
GCS layer were multi-region anyway it
was easy for us to do so and another
kind of could be better that out
call-out is so for example that April
issue had an amazing post-mortem but the
junior shouldn't so it's all a great
learning experience to learn about you
know what went wrong we can understand
more about how everything works
internally and sometimes it kind of can
get to action items for us that if you
could do this we could kind of protect
ourselves a little bit more but overall
I think it's a great time to be out
there and building products on these
cloud platforms that you don't have to
think about so many kind of complex and
sophisticated infrastructure things
Google given its scale with search has
solved these problems they kind of their
infrastructure works for mind-boggling
scale and complexity and it's great that
they have they are making it available
for other peoples to use it through
their cloud infrastructure I mean which
other company in this world can think of
building a spanner for example right but
as users of it it still takes work it
still takes a lot of thought on how do
you want to go about it it still takes
dedication it still takes
bring up with a cohesive plan and making
trade-offs so with that I'll conclude my
talk thank you very much for listening
and if you have any questions I can take
so thank you thanks a lot that was
terrific presentation I think that
everyone here has enjoyed it because
I've got the special mic I'll kick off
with a few questions just to start one
of the first things I thought the crowd
might be interested in hearing about is
you talked a lot about multi cloud there
can you talk a little bit about the
egress cost there and what that's been
like for thumbtack right so we're kind
of exporting a lot of data out of AWS so
we are mainly talking about Tigres costs
in AWS it's not been that high in the
sense that like for example our scoop
jobs still run every single time they
run they kind of take the entire data
base snapshot there are some kind of
nice to have optimizations we could have
streaming replication into Google which
would reduce the guest costs but overall
those figures are like not that high
that we have to drop everything and fix
that thing right now like I said again
this goes in terms of how we think about
our time we kind of prioritize products
and projects that are important to our
company's top-line first but all in all
I think the egress costs are pretty much
under control and manageable that's
great thank you and so I think another
thing you've talked a lot about where
you've been and where you've come to
what's next for you at thumbtack what
are you thinking about in terms of the
new use cases you're going after or
what's next for your infrastructure
there as you think about data and
analytics in particular right so having
the robust infrastructure like this for
base data processing really becomes a
foundation on which we can build some
more sophisticated and complex
processing we are now trying to invest a
lot into our machine learning
infrastructure views using tensorflow
currently we are using tensorflow
serving on AWS but we would like to kind
of evaluate cloud ml as well as we are
kind of evaluating data flow to kind of
create the feature extraction pipelines
that we could run in both streaming and
batch modes so those are some of the
things that kind of are coming up
the pipeline that sounds great and if I
might just one more question for you
before let's open it up to the audience
when you think about you know what we
can do from a Google perspective or what
other services that we could potentially
offer is there anything in our stack
that you'd like to see that maybe you're
not currently seeing that we could be
working on yeah
so I think one of the things that I
missed on Google infrastructure while
setting up everything was having a pop
subsystem that supported some level of
partial ordering I'm a huge fan of the
Kafka paradigm of messaging Kafka or
Apache poles or both have some partial
ordering so that enables for example you
to have like database streams into your
pop subsystem Google pops up kind of has
taken a different philosophy for
scalability they have traded off the
ordering part that's because the Google
data flows stream processing pipeline is
very feature-rich it can do some event
I'm been doing and reorder there but if
you are not really using that we would
really want to see if some heavy lifting
done on the pub/sub side I think that
would be very useful for us and I've
recently learned that I think confluent
and Google are partnering to set up
managed Kafka and GCP so that's
something we'll check it out and see
what what we can build on top of that
[Music]